Shayne Irving is here and he's he went
to three and one last week he's 29 27 in
for his bets with the front row you lost
and you want so yeah so where do we
stand with the front row bets
I think I'm up like a thousand days
feels like might be the other way around
Paulie where does it stand you even I
don't think he's down two or three
hundred of us we rolled with army last
week by the way seat and paid off his
wheel of punishment bet he does have his
shirt on it looks good yeah thank you
all right your your picks this week
nothing but bangers Danny of course I
got the Beavers plus seven and a half I
got the Ducks minus two I got Texas Tech
plus six and a half I got the Gophers
plus seven and a half
Lobos minus two and a half and the
Baptist plus ten okay that's Baylor
about that kiss yeah all right Paulie
you got that front row do you have a
front row bet there Shane who offers
this work I'm certain you do okay what
do you present for bets - you pick any
two that you like any - I got a pick -
yes for 40 bucks each what if I want to
pick one for 100 that is not what's on
the table doing is aggressive when
you're ahead you can make the rule ok
Seaton and I have Yale given three and a
half to Harvard from the outright Ivy
League title at home at the Yale ball
next bet
Navy getting 18 chips from Notre Dame we
would take Navy Iowa is given seven and
a half - Purdue will take Iowa army
shocker getting two and a half versus
North Texas on the road we would take
army because they've they're buying a
new wing on the house this year yeah
okay I get it I'm taking I'm taking
North Texas because I attempted to go to
school there once okay couldn't find the
campus so I dropped out and what
Auriemma Yale Harvard Navy Notre Dame
Iowa Purdue give me Harvard is plus
three that's right
Harvard plus three lock it in Pauley
locked in okay is the navy quarterback
is that perry kid is his ankle healthy
enough healthy enough to beat cover
against Notre Dame Lee not the cover
yeah well he better play if he plays
then you got a chance there keep an eye
on cuz that kid that kid was great I got
a bet Danny yeah what's the over-under I
want over unreal now on the ginger
hammer getting fired by Jerry Jones
bringing the revolution how about that
if they don't make the playoffs yeah I'm
saying the ginger hammer doesn't get a
new contract give me plus odds there
well now he's got an excuse he didn't
have a zekiel Elliott or Tyrone Smith or
Sean lien yeah Roger Goodell will not be
the Commissioner in the NFL give me odds
oh wow give me odds he doesn't get a new
contract doesn't get one anybody want to
jump in on a che wheel of punishment
here whoa hey you I don't bet I don't I
can't gamble just bet the ball boy for a
seat in your chair so I don't want to
talk about you and your gambling life is
ruined the America's dream I pet Mannix
you're killing ears Annie nationwide
nationwide
I bet man why do you have a problem with
Chris Mannix because it's Boston sports
radio Danny if I wanted to listen to
that I Drive up in Worcester and park in
a parking lot that's what I do but I
don't
okay I don't want a bet because it's a
gateway drug and I don't want to go back
down that road you should I use to be
you and I don't want to be you and you
were happy no I was not of his miserable
family in your misery I was not I was
just like my misery comfortable in your
misery I got a little too comfortable at
home in your misery I had to get out of
the cellar that was in trouble
I loved the mind and I and I was winning
too I just hated it I did yeah everybody
hates win and that's American as apple
pie I did I dropped a 3300 on the game I
remember that was the last one and that
was yet I walked away didn't you get a
washing machine I did I bought my mom a
washing machine and then you quit and
then I quit like a communist away I
can't do it I hated watching game I
don't need to have money on a game to
watch again why do you think DirecTV
even exist any the NFL package you think
anybody cares about the Rams game some
dude in Ohio's watching that for one
reason and one reason only
on it I know but I don't need idea I
can't do it
I cannot have money bet on this does
anybody but your citizens anybody want a
piece of che with either the ginger
doesn't survive and get a new contract
what's that mean what's a thousand no
that's straight up
no that ain't straight up straight oh
that's that's ten spins the one then
Danny Paulie
I'll parlay I will no leave me alone
well partly Jason Garrett is still the
coach next year no Roger Goodell is
still the commissioner next that's not
fair combo parlay shake and bake that's
minus 5,000 those gingers survived that
ain't right Jason Garrett will not get
fired as long as Gerald Jones is alive
period he's got another puppet so that's
ixnay that I'm saying the ginger hammer
is not gonna survive Gerald Jones's
wrath that's my point
you think the Commissioner is doesn't
get a contract extension I would like to
make a bet on that okay what is the bet
I need plus a thousand ten spins the one
yeah no I know
I can't gamble anymore I'm not gonna do
it so I don't I can't know whatever
ma'am right we got two picks Shea and
Irving the picture on the website is by
the way the million dollar better is up
two million on these ticks just want you
to know who's the million dollar bet
whoever is following my picks and
betting a million they're up two million
really if you look at what am i 29 and
27 yeah that's up two million Danny if
you're betting a million yeah you're
welcome
what 40 no I'm just thinking about his
bet and uh no don't do it don't do it
don't yeah you yeah you're gonna end up
you're gonna end up wheel punishment
with the Cleveland Browns
all right shades great see you have a
great weekend and maybe we'll see you at
the tailgate at Harvard you want to join
Paulie and I you go Harvard yeah let's
do it
hey Paulie tailgating with him yeah
that'd be fun flasks at 8:00 a.m. any
trouble flasks and half staff for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
you
[Music]